字幕: Kayoko Shiomi
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
「まぜこぜの社会」
どんなことをイメージしますか？
私 これ「混ぜご飯」から思いついたんです
「混ぜご飯」って手の込んだお料理なんです
例えば 海老は塩煎り 椎茸は甘辛く煮る
絹さやは塩茹で 卵は金糸に焼く
それぞれの食材を生かした
下準備 下ごしらえをすれば
美味しいお料理になるんです
最後に
ご飯と混ぜ合わせて
社会もこれと同じです
多様性社会だ さあ みんな生きよう！
ではなくて
それぞれの特性に合わせた配慮があれば
生きやすい 居心地の良い社会を
作ることができると思います
多様性社会
よくカタカナで表現されますよね
ダイバーシティ インクルーシブネス
ノーマライゼーション
もしかしたら ちょっとなんか距離がある
ピンとこない
よそごとのような感じがするかもしれません
なので 「まぜこぜの社会」
どうです 親近感が湧きませんか？
私は４年間の会社員生活を経て
芸能界に入りました
そして 情報報道番組の司会につきました
その時のディレクターの一人が
私に教えてくれたんです
「政治と報道は困った人のために
あるんですよ」と
これが私の軸にあるんだと思うんですね
それから 32歳の時に
社会活動をスタートさせました
それが 私のタイミングだったんだと思います
将来「私は何もしなかった
何もできなかった」と
後悔するのではなくて
私は私を活用したいと思ったんです
そして私自身のためです
困ったときに救ってくれようとする
社会じゃないと 私は不安です
それから30年間
ボランティア活動が続いています
骨髄バンク ドイツ国際平和村
障害者アートなどなどの
多岐に渡る活動をずっと繰り広げています
そして 12年前には団体を立ち上げてしまい
翌年には法人化してしまいました
してしまいました
というのはですね
私は団体とか組織が苦手なんですよ
だから会社を辞めたんですよ
徒党を組むとか 何とかファミリーとか
スクラム組むっていうのは どうも無縁で
子供の頃から「よそ様に迷惑をかけては
いけません」と言われて育ったので
団体や組織に属さなければ
誰にも迷惑をかけない
その方が楽と思ったんですね
それで 全国各地 その都度
行政や企業や学校や
組織さんたちと一緒に
こう転々 全国各地で転々転々転って
活動をずっと広げてきたんです
ですが 団体が嫌だなんて
言っていられない事態が起きました
2011年3月11日 東日本大震災
あの時の被災地の避難所
日本の縮図でしたよ
本来の日本の姿です
色々な人達が集いました
メディアは 力強い優しい言葉を
いっぱい出しました
つながろう がんばろう 絆
寄り添う 思いやり 頑張ろう 頑張ろう
ですが 頑張れない人たちもいたんです
とりこぼされる人たちもいたんです
例えば 車椅子ユーザーさんは
ここの避難所は バリアフリーではないから
他所の方がいいんじゃないですかと
やんわりと排除をされたり
見えない 聞こえない人は
配給物資を十分に入手できなかったり
自閉症の子がワーッとパニックを起こしたら
「うるさい！」って怒鳴られたり
障害のあるお子さんがいるご家族は
入室をためらったり
トランスジェンダーは
トイレやお風呂を困ったり
「私は皆さんの足手まといになりたくないから
おじいちゃんのところに避難します」と
書置きを残して お爺ちゃんのお墓の前で
自ら命を絶ったおばあちゃんもいました
ショックでしたね
普段から生きづらさを抱えている人たちが
社会が不安に陥った時に
より追い詰められてしまうという
厳しい現実があったんです
なんでこんなことになるんだろう
そして メディアは
あんまり取り上げなかったんです
デリケートなことだからと
きっと 普段から
「私たちはすでに共に生きている」という
実感がないんだと思います
活動している人たち
私たちって みんな同じ思いなんですよ
「私たちは大切にしてほしい」
「自分の思う幸せを追い求められる社会がいい」
シンプルなことです
これは人権を守ってほしいっていう
活動なんです
同じ思いなんですけれども
活動の仕方が縦割り
これがもったいないんですよ
施設とか団体とか学校とか
いろんなものを横串を刺す
つなげていくハブになる団体が
あればいいのにと思いました
それで 立ち上げました
一般社団法人「Get in touch」
学校 企業 支援団体 福祉団体 省庁
家族 個人 超党派の政治家
みんなをつなげていく活動をしています
じゃあ どうやってやるか
こういったイベント 講演 シンポジウム
意識の高い皆さんのような方が集まります
もうすごい頼もしい 心強い
今日こうやってつながれて嬉しいです
皆さんのこと大好きです
リアクションして
（笑）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
こうした活動に興味がない
社会なんて変わらない
私の周りには障害者やLGBTQはいないと
思い込んでいる人たちともつながりたいんです
その人たちとも巻き込みたいんです
何が必要か
ワクワクときめくことがいいですよね
エンターテイメントです
アート 音楽 映像 舞台などを通じて
新しい時間 空間 人間関係を使って
「あれ 自分と違う人たちが
すでにこんなにいるんだ
あれ ちょっと待て
今まで何だった？
あれ？フツウってなんだろう？」
っていうふうに
一緒に考えていきたいんです
なので メンバーは様々なんですよ
カメラマン 音楽関係 美術関係 映像監督
デザイナー ライター ジャーナリスト
クリエイター以外にも サラリーマン
手話通訳士 事務局
とにかくありとあらゆる
職業の私たちです
ジェンダーもセクシャリティもゼネレーションも
障害のあるなしも
もうとにかく 立場もキャリアも様々な
私たちが集まっているので
様々なアイデアが湧きます
なので 色とりどりの取り組みができています
同時多発的に 多様なコンテンツを
展開しているんですが
今日ご紹介するのはこちら
「まぜこぜ一座」です
みんなプロのパフォーマー シンガー
ミュージシャン ダンサー 手品師
とにかくいろいろな
プロの人たちなんですけれども
エンターテナーですけれども
特性は車椅子 義足
全盲 ダウン症 自閉症
小人 ドラァグクイーン
トランスジェンダー
とにかく
マイノリティーと呼ばれている人達です
私は企画や構成や出演や演出もしていて
あと 企業協賛への交渉とか
雑用とか
力仕事とか謝罪とか
とにかく謝罪が大事なのよ
とにかく何でもやるっていう形で
東奔西走しています
このまぜこぜ一座は
映像制作や舞台公演を展開しています
90分の映像―
『MAZEKOZEアイランドツアー』
というのも制作しました
これ 今も
オンラインで観ることができます
森田かずよさん
義足のダンサーです
彼女の撮影をしているときに
カメラマンにお願いをしました
「かずよさんに途中で
義足を外してもらいます
綺麗にその脚を撮ってください」
っていうふうに
かずよさんは
華麗な素晴らしいダンスを披露して
足を高く上げて
義足をドラマチックにパチンパチンと外して
床にドンと義足を落としたんですね
カメラは彼女の脚をアップ…
にするはずだったんですが
カメラは彼女の顔にバーンと逃げたんですね
撮影ストップ
カメラマン冷や汗
「本当に撮っていいんでしょうか...？」
「彼女の足は唯一無二です
魅力の一つです
美しく撮りましょう
実際 私は美しいと思っています」
こんなこともありました
「自閉症のキャストにフツウに話しかけて
いいんでしょうか？」
こんなことも
「小人は放送自粛用語です
なので低身長という障害のあるタレントに
修正してください」
と指摘を受けたり
その度にスタッフや本人と
対話を重ねて議論をして
妥協したり 諦めたり 解決したり
ちなみに 小人という表現は
やっぱり日本はまだNGワードらしいんですね
でもそれを受け入れてたら 彼らの活躍する
チャンスがなくなっちゃうんですよね
なので 私は『MAZEKOZEアイランドツアー』
では共演しています
「こびとーず」という風に
ネーミングをしてみました
はい
ま アイデア次第
カメラマンから 撮影が全部終わって
報告があったんです
「東さん 僕変わったんです
以前は障害のある人を見かけたら
見て見ぬふりをする
それがマナー
礼儀だと思っていました
でも そうなると
存在しなかったことになりますよね
僕今ね 困ってないかな？って
フツウに話しかけられるんです
あ 僕フツウって言っちゃった
フツウって何なんすかね？」って
苦笑いをしていました
嬉しかったですね
やってよかったと思いました
制作の疲れが吹っ飛んだ瞬間でした
要はね
彼は不慣れだったんですよ
正しい知識がないからって 遠慮してたんです
でも「遠慮」よりこれです
「配慮」です
正しい知識や理解がなくても 一緒にいるとね
分かってくることがたくさんあるんです
誤解や思い込みから
迷惑をかけたり 傷つけあったりとか
間違い 失敗もあるかもしれない
そういう時は謝って
何が要因だったのかを知って
どうすることができるかに
気づいていけばいいんですよね
私はね
もうその積み重ねの30年です
今もわからないことだらけです
あの
わからないと言えばですね
これ
「社会の役立つ人になろう」
私これ何かね
モヤモヤするんですよね
逆じゃないでしょうかね
「人の役に立つ社会をつくろう」
だと思います
だって 健常者？
常に健やかな者なんていないですよ
私たちは
みんな人間は歳を重ねるし
もしかしたら不自由
不具合な体になるかもしれないし
病人になるかもしれない
そのために福祉があるんです
福祉は特別の人のためのものではないんです
福祉は私たち全員 すべての人が幸せを
追い求められるためのものなんです
どんな状況でも どんな状態でも
誰も排除しない 誰も排除されない
「まぜこぜの社会」
私はそれがいいと思うんですよね
こういうことを言うとね
「それは理想論だ　頭の中がお花畑だ」と
言われることもあります
でも 理想を追い求められる社会の方が
安心でしょう　いいでしょう
理想を語れなくなる社会は怖すぎます
一人で語る理想は
妄想に過ぎないかもしれませんが
皆さんとつながる理想は
現実になると思います
皆さん 浅く広くゆるくつながりましょう
浅く広くゆるくでいいんです
時に深くつながりあって 支え合って
救い合ってね
いざというときは
ご縁という糸を紡いで
つながっていきましょう！
さあ みんなで一緒に
「まぜこぜの社会」を目指しましょう！
(拍手)
ありがとうございました
（拍手）